God works in mysterious ways the man
calling me a misogynist came out and
this week had his wife sleep with a porn
star for money and now he has been all
over the Internet coping coping coping
coping Adam 22 has changed his tune over
the years I mean he's always felt this
way right King he he's always just
wanted to let his girl get railed he's
always been perfectly comfortable with
it because that's what the left and
women are going to convince you that you
should naturally be comfortable with
this and if you are not comfortable with
letting your girl get railed by other
dudes you are just insecure how to touch
man